vous le savez vous le vivez tous les
jours tout coûte plus cher à l'épicerie
elle est taux d'intérêt qui augmente
donc votre loyer augmente votre
protecteur augmente mais les salaires ne
suivent pas nécessairement cette
tendance le gouvernement Trudeau
reconnaît maintenant que des ventes de
face vont bientôt souffler sur le pays
je pense que c'est important aussi
d'être franche d'être honnête avec les
gens
et pour nous tous de comprendre que
nous sommes dans une situation
compliquée
dans le monde dans l'économie mondiale
et ça veut dire que on aura on aura des
effets ici aussi
alors doit-on créer une récession
comment va-t-elle nous affecter j'ai
parlé un peu plus tôt avec les mains
Gignac économiste et sénateurs
indépendant du Québec et ancien ministre
également mais tout d'abord écoutons
quelques échanges aux communes cet
après-midi
l'année prochaine les Canadiens paieront
une autre 3000 dollars par famille pour
cette inflation que le premier ministre
à causé quand va-t-il renverser ces
politiques inflationnistes une chose est
en désaccord avec notre nos propositions
d'aider les familles sur une autre chose
entièrement d'essayer d'empêcher cette
taille d'arriver dans les poches des
familles qui en ont besoin probable que
on va avoir une récession ici au Canada
mais ce gouveron n'a pas une plante
est-ce que ce gouvernement va livrer un
plan où est-ce qu'il va attendre que les
gens souffrent déjà avant d'agir on va
commencer travailler avec tous les
parlementaires pour livrer pour les gens
qui font face à des difficultés
chauffage va coûter plus cher ça veut
dire que le transport va coûter plus
cher et donc incidemment la nourriture
va coûter plus cher mais monsieur le
Président le gouvernement libéral a
refusé de baisser les taxes est-ce que
le premier ministre est conscient qu'en
agissant de la sorte il crée l'inflation
alors il couperait où les conservateurs
est-ce que c'est au niveau les enfants
qui ont besoin d'un coup de pouce parce
que ce niveau des garderies est-ce que
c'est pour les familles c'est bien
facile critiquer monsieur le Président
mais pas le courage de dire qu'est-ce
qui ferait en place parce qu'on aurait
fait la place et faire ce que tous les
pays du G7 c'est-à-dire baisser les
taxes
[Applaudissements]
le gouvernement là ont refusé de baisser
les taxes monsieur le Président
bonsoir Clément qui est bien de 24 x 100
bonsoir on va essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe vous avez entendu la
ministre des Finances dire qu'elle ne va
pas dorer la pilule elle va être honnête
avec les canadienne le Premier ministre
qui dit on a des vents contraires en
fait ce qu'on nous dit c'est que ça va
faire mal bientôt on va être en
récession pourquoi allons-nous tomber en
récession mais clairement être qu'on
prépare le terrain là on voit bien du
côté de tawa des temps plus difficiles
écoutez c'est pas compliqué mais en fait
faut reculer peut-être le un ennemi
lorsqu'on avait des signes l'inflation
s'accélérer je pense que les banques
centrales ont tardé pour juste au Canada
ailleurs aussi à réagir on pensait à
l'époque ça prend l'histoire et là
maintenant on prend les bouchées doubles
et on augmente très rapidement les taux
d'intérêt et donc ça fait mal mais en
même temps je voudrais Anne-Marie
rassurer des gens oui il y aura sans
doute une récession mais une récession
c'est pas une dépression économique là
on parle pas d'une augmentation de 5-6%
du dommage puisque au moment on se parle
il y a deux postes vacants d'être
disponibles par chômeur donc oui il va
avoir un ralentissement d'activité
économique il y a des secteurs qui vont
être plus affectés que d'autres on peut
penser à l'immobilier notamment par
contre c'est pas vrai là que toutes les
secteurs vont être affectés également
puis c'est pas vrai non plus que toutes
les provinces et les régions vont être
affectées de la même façon mais c'est
quand même une roue qui tourne tout
directeur est à 3.25 la Banque du Canada
pourrait continuer de l'augmenter même
chose aux États-Unis mais
on a l'impression qu'on provoque la
récession qu'on l'invite parce que on
augmente les taux d'intérêt pour freiner
l'économie puis pauvre fantôme en
récession puis ça tu l'épingle ça tue
les les réels des gens enfin ça fait du
mal de récession
casser deux hors actuellement la demande
est beaucoup trop forte contenue de
l'offre l'offre qui contraint par des
problèmes de chaîne de provisionnement
de tension aussi qu'on a au niveau du
géopolitique le prix la matière première
donc on veut ralentir l'économie qui
poussait les gouvernements on peut le
voir aussi certains gouvernements qui
ont envoyé aussi des chèques à peu près
à tout le monde qui fait en sorte que ce
souci ça a alimenté la banque
l'inflation donc à ce moment-là on veut
avoir une politique restrictive pour
ralentir cette demande puis c'est vrai
que ça va faire mal à des endroits au
niveau de la Bourse oui on constate
quand une récession admirée
habituellement la bourse recule de 25 à
30% par contre pour les gens qui ont des
visions plus un peu à moyen terme trois
quatre ans on récupère ce qu'on a perdu
mais clairement oui ça va faire mal
c'est surtout les nouveaux propriétaires
de maison le client a acheté une maison
avec des taux d'intérêt très faible
quand vient le temps de renouveler ça ça
va faire plus plus ça va plus difficile
évidemment gérer c'est comme si on avait
le choix entre deux mots pourquoi on
privilégié on privilégie de lutter
contre l'INFE l'inflation qui est à
tomber en récession plutôt que de
laisser aller les choses et dire ben on
va voir ce qu'il fait le moins
l'inflation succession c'est une très
bonne question à ma vie mais l'inflation
c'est pire qu'une version pourquoi
fallait l'inflation en fait avec tout le
monde puis qui plus est faite les plus
démunis de la société on ne se penser au
niveau du loyer au niveau de
l'alimentation qui représente un poids
bien plus important dans leur budget que
pour les plus riches donc l'inflation
affecte tout le monde et en particulier
les plus démunis une récession n'a fait
pas tout le monde en fait c'est un
pourcentage et en plus pour la première
fois en 50 ans il y a plus de postes
vacants actuellement que de chômeurs qui
fait en sorte que ça se peut que vous
perdez votre emploi mais moyennement de
formation puisse recycler dans un autre
secteur puis une récession s'est
temporaire habituellement ça dure en 6 à
9 mois et qui plus est selon les
prévisions papa d'une récession sévère
comme on a véhicule le 12-13 est-ce
qu'on va revenir un inflation est-ce
qu'on peut soit normal et mis 2% après
cette récession là en plein cas cette
prestation est-ce qu'on revient à
[Musique]
les banques centrales sont très très
sérieuses en leur volonté de ramener
ceux à la cible de 2% qu'on a depuis
1990 donc l'idée c'est que ils vont
faire ce qu'il faut pour ramener ça et
qui plus est les attentes
inflationnistes la bonne nouvelle en
Marie c'est que un peu plus tôt cette
semaine avant du Canada sortait leur
publications au niveau des sondages des
entreprises et du côté des ménages et on
voit que les ménages et les entreprises
continuent à croire que l'inflation
d'ici trois quatre ans va rester en deçà
de 3% on va revenir en bas de 3 poissons
je devrais dire et ça c'est encourageant
puisque la pire ce serait de laisser
aller le répéterait ce qu'on a vécu dans
les années 70 c'était pas juste
l'inflation on parlait de stagnation qui
était la combinaison des deux d'une
recule de l'activité économique avec une
inflation très forte aux États-Unis ça
promet de mettre l'enjeu de l'élection
la banque américaine va continuer
semble-t-il d'augmenter les taux en
Royaume-Uni on voit que c'est la
catastrophe et en tout annulé
continue à la case départ renie leur
promesse il y a nul les baisses des
taxes si vous avez entendu les
conservateurs tout à l'heure vous êtes
un sénateur indépendant mais nommé quand
même par les libéraux vous étiez
ministre dans un gouvernement provincial
libéral peut-être que vous avez
peut-être un petit billet de ce côté-là
mais vous avez quand même entendu
entendu les conservateurs dire faut
baisser les taxes faut baisser les taxes
justement on a eu un débat cet
après-midi au Sénat puis je comprends
l'addition pouvait faire mais on est
quand même indépendant j'ai des amis du
côté des conservateurs
l'idée c'est que oui moi je trouve que
la façon qu'on approche sexuellement au
niveau du fédéral c'est à dire d'avoir
un crédité d'impôt le remboursement pour
la TPS pour les plus démunis ceux qui
ont gang de moins de 30000 dollars c'est
ça qu'on doit faire on doit couler ça
sera une erreur d'abaisser la TPS par
exemple pourquoi parce que
temporairement oui on va baisser
tranquillement l'inflation on va
stimuler l'économie est-ce que ça
voudrait dire c'est que la base du
Canada va monter taux d'intérêt encore
plus haut et qui plus est maintenant il
faut leur ramener la TPS au niveau
précédent donc on fait juste reporter le
problème en avant donc je trouve que oui
c'est pas idéal mais c'est quand même la
meilleure solution c'est de cibler les
gouvernementale au plus démunis puisque
c'est eux qui sont le plus affectés par
l'inflation et comme vous avez été
ministre quand même à Québec est-ce que
les deux paliers de gouvernement ont un
rôle à jouer pour soutenir les
contribuables dans cette période de
l'impact parce que tout va augmenter
l'état municipales on l'a vu dans la rue
au Québec foncière augmente et des frais
qui augmentent partout les salaires
augmentent pas pour tout le monde il y
en a qui reste pris dans un échelon où
il y en a pas plus dans leur poche les
garderies coûte cher parce qu'il y en a
pas assez de enfin vous voyez le cercle
vicieux dans lequel les citoyens se
retrouvent vous avez raison premièrement
les salaires ne sont pas à l'origine de
l'inflation c'est des raisons externes
des salaires en sont en mode rattrapage
puisque c'est une perte de poids d'achat
actuellement et des salaires qui
augmentent moins mais la bonne chose à
faire des gouvernements et là je
m'adresse également au gouvernement le
goût c'est pas d'envoyer des chèques de
500 ou 1000 pièces à tout le monde c'est
de cibler au Québec on a un crédit
d'impôt pour la solidarité vaut
justement les gens plus démunis qui
puisse avoir ça un peu comme le fédéral
fait également donc moi c'est sûr que
j'espère que les gouvernements vont
faire preuve de discipline budgétaire
mais vont venir en aide au plus démunis
puisque l'inflation touche les plus
démunis parce qu'on sait aussi même les
Banques Alimentaires n'en peuvent plus
ils sont à sec les gens recourent de
plus en plus ces banques alimentaires
une nouvelle clientèle les étudiants
notamment
dernière question sur le contexte est-ce
que tout ça est relié à la guerre en
Ukraine notamment aux conséquent de la
pandémie en terminant on peut pas tout
imputer à la guerre à l'Ukraine parce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres enjeux qui
est au niveau des chaînes
d'approvisionnement non et également des
entreprises qui en ont profité on va le
dire pour augmenter leur prix en mettant
ça sur d'autres l'Ukraine donc oui l'U
joue une partie surtout au début le
quand on parle d'un prix du pétale qui
était à 120$ le Berry mais on voit
maintenant le prix de l'essence qui
descend donc on est bien au-delà de
l'Ukraine et je crois aussi que on va
appel à la responsabilité des
entreprises de faire preuve un peu plus
de responsabilité de pas en profiter
pour augmenter des prix en mettant ça
sur le dos de l'Ukraine et je pense que
du côté de faut s'attendre que le temps
va monter de la part du gouvernement à
la gare des entreprises qui utilisent
l'Ukraine comme des fêtes pour augmenter
leur prix on se laisse là-dessus de
marginiac merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI